this is from uh daily wire lebron james
has found a way to sink to a new low
daily wire reports nba star lebron james
posted a photograph on social media on
wednesday
of the police officer who allegedly shot
and killed a 16-year-old girl in
columbus ohio
writing your next hashtag accountability
um and then let's see
the the national fraternal order of
police responded to james's tweet by
writing
uh king james with his vast resources
influence
should educate himself and frankly has a
responsibility to do so on the facts
before weighing in this is disgraceful
and extremely reckless
the officer saved a young girl's life no
amount of gaslighting
will change that now lebron did go
and um i think he deleted the tweet
didn't really apologize for it
he deleted that one and then later
tweeted again
defending it and saying uh i get so
upset about uh black
black people getting killed by the cops
and that's what this is all about we
need to count
accountability that's what he keeps
saying
um and yes that's what i open the show
with
i i agree accountability
be accountable for your children how
about that
you got a 16 year old girl out trying to
stab someone to death
and yes we can say stab someone to death
we can say that she was trying to kill
someone
knives kill people
hundreds of people a year in fact in
this country killed by knives
believe it or not it's a it's a really
common thing
and that knife the size of that knife
that was one that
it gets you place it in the in the right
place
um on someone's body you could kill them
on the spot yeah
so if your daughter's out doing that
accountability
parental accountability literally be
accountable for your children
know what they're doing be there for
them how about that
but but lebron again um this is
lebron's a very stupid person and and we
have to remember that
um but he also still knows better
he he definitely knows better
and he's in a position where this i mean
this is lebron james this is the most
famous athlete in the world a massive
massive platform
and he takes this cop who saved a girl's
life a woman's life
um and puts his puts his
picture out there says you're next
he should be brought that's that should
be criminal you should be brought up on
criminal charges for that
you're trying to get the guy killed
what what do you mean you're next what
are you even referring to
because the cop didn't commit a crime so
you can't say you're next in terms of
criminal prosecution you didn't commit a
crime
what he did was perfectly legal that
justified him good
it's good that he did it it is good when
cops
stop people from stabbing other people
that's a good thing
so what do you mean by you're next that
seems an awful lot like you're trying to
send a violent mob
you from your massive platform while
you're tweeting
from your multi-million dollar mansion
seems an awful lot like you're trying to
send a violent mob after this guy
well i hope you enjoyed that clip for
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe
button right down there so you can stay
up to date on all of our future content